take a look at ford's f-series the
best-selling truck in america for over
35 years
North American production analyst at lmc
automotive Jeff Schuster says it's
always been their bread and butter and
it will continue to be this truck is for
endless routinely used the nice round
figure of ten thousand dollars when
plugging profit numbers for the f-150
into their models meaning operating
margins can extend north of fifteen
percent that number obviously varies
depending on the model the f-150 starts
at twenty six thousand dollars for the
basic two door two wheel drive XL but
runs quickly past seventy eight thousand
dollars for a fully loaded at 450 and of
course stiffer competition or
overproduction can weigh on margins
because it forces the manufacturer to
offer incentives that eat into profits a
change in production can also affect
margins with the recent switch to
aluminum bodies Ford's production
dropped by forty percent in the first
quarter and overall North American
margins a number the company actually
does publish dropped from what would
have been over ten percent to just six
point seven percent chief financial
officer Bob shanks says thank God for
the f-150 adding that once the truck
reaches full production in July it will
drive a breakthrough year for profit
Morgan Stanley analyst Adam Jonas says
ford's f-series makes up ninety percent
of the company's automotive profit in
fact in some years it's more than one
hundred percent because everything else
actually loses money
in the months that led up to the great
recession when oversupply led to the
bankruptcy of General Motors and
Chrysler all three Detroit car makers
offered such big incentives that they
lost money on all of their cars it was
only the trucks that kept Ford afloat